hi everyone so my name is Nikita I'm a
founding ml engineer at Galileo and
today
um as if you mentioned I'll be talking
about critical errors and ml data sets
and at the end I'll demo how Galileo can
fix them for you
so
um what is our so our thesis is that
model performance is an 80 20 problem
and what I mean by that is 20 of the
performance gains come from tuning model
architectures loss functions training
schedules Etc the stuff that machine
learning practitioners have been pretty
focused on for the last few years you
know as the industry has matured but 80
of it still comes from fixing the data
and this could be mislabels class
confusion data imbalance data drift and
these are things that we as
practitioners haven't actually spent
much time historically thinking about
which is kind of crazy because we think
that it contributes the most to the
ventral model's performance
um so yeah today I'll be covering these
data errors there's definitely more but
these are perhaps the largest categories
as we see it and at the end I'll give a
quick demo how Galileo can fix that
so what is mislabeled data so
essentially this is when the given label
doesn't equal the actual label and what
I mean by that for example is in an
image classification task where a
labeler was given you know a picture and
they have to assign one of let's say
like 20 categories to it I'm here for
example is the Quick Draw data set on
the left the labeler was shown what
looks to be a line but they labeled it
as a hexagon and this is these are all
examples of errors in public data sets
that are used for for example sketch
recognition models
so on the second from the left
the circle was given the label of dog
you have it um what looks like a
calendar given the label jail and a
banana slash Moon given the label of
knife
similarly in imagenet super popular you
know canonical data set and computer
vision
um Rife with tons of different kinds of
data errors so on the left it was given
a label of kite but looks very clearly
to be a bald eagle paper towel
that should be dock
and we'll get back to this one a little
bit more later but um it was labeled tow
truck whereas it looks to be a garbage
truck although it's hard to see because
it's zoomed in and then ant labeled as b
or B labeled as ant
it's not only limited to computer vision
also NLP text classification has tons of
these for example the conventent data
set where uh your the like model is
essentially given an utterance and it
has to predict the intent so as you
might imagine like a voice assistant in
your home so booking a restaurant often
was gang labeled as get weather and so
on yeah
so why does mislabeled data happen and
part of it has to do with your labeling
platform and essentially your budget at
the end of the day how many labelers get
to review each sample and whether
they're rotated to limit their bias if
you've ever tried to you know label an
entire data set or a decent chunk of it
you'll notice that or at least we've
noticed that over time you start to
develop very strict definitions in your
head about how to label these that might
not correspond with other waivers so
it's important for the labeling platform
to not only rotate labelers through the
data set but also have multiple labelers
and review each sample
also sometimes the task is difficult so
for example
um perhaps there's some a domain
knowledge that labelers might know maybe
it's a healthcare data set and you
ultimately need doctors to be the ones
to label it also sometimes there's not a
lot of room for error this might happen
in scenarios where multiple labels might
apply to the same example
um things like that
so one other reason is that classes can
also just be confusing and we'll cover
this more in the class overlap data
error
so how does someone go about fixing
these there's actually been a decent
amount of research and like work in the
past few years
um so part of what we've been doing at
Galileo and
um with other other like research
projects out there is making these
algorithms easier to use and easier to
put into your systems but the historical
way is just to start with making the
labeler's life easier so this could be
more specific instructions for areas
that you might expect them to struggle
with or areas that you've like manually
seen them struggle with it could be you
know better labeling platforms better
tooling to you know help them give more
accurate labels and sometimes yeah
choosing easier task types whether
that's making the domain easier like for
example limiting the number of classes
um you know in a lot of CV data sets
there's hundreds and hundreds of classes
and that can be pretty hard for labelers
to efficiently choose
so yeah looking at labeler agreement is
a very common thing that the labeling
platforms will hopefully automatically
do for you
um you know if there's a lot of
disagreement on a label you can then
have that like
further reviewed and sent to even more
labelers things like that
and finally like I mentioned there's
been research in algorithmically
detecting these so that can come from a
few lots of different ways of doing this
but it all basically comes from using
the model's training signals to inform
an algorithm which samples are
mislabeled
so for example you could look at the
variance and the sample's loss over the
epochs another very common method is to
look at how certain the model is in the
non-given class as in if the labeler
said it was dog but the model very
strongly thinks it's cat and that's a
signal that indicates you know perhaps
the labeler was wrong
and finally there's also a way of
comparing two similar samples from the
data set using the model's embeddings
and this can also indicate whether you
know if all the samples that look just
like this have a deferring label well
it's there's likely some error
yeah
so moving on to class overlap
um like if you remember that example
from the Quick Draw data set where there
was a banana or Moon
um yeah sometimes things can just be
difficult and labelers end up fighting
over what the correct class is without
any chance of success
so for example going back to Quick Draw
I'm here are a bunch of examples and you
know you might have deferring opinions
on what constitutes one class or the
other but it's pretty evident that um
no one's really set up for success in
labeling these so computer or laptop
well those are kind of the same classes
but in quick draw those are different uh
snake or snorkel snorkel in this case
this specific example could be the
confused between the two pizza or wheel
and squiggle or zigzag
similarly for imagenet there's a bunch
of dog breeds in here that can be very
difficult to label if you're not
um
you know highly attuned to the
differences between an otter Hound
affenpincher or briard and also for
example on that second from the Right
image it's super zoomed in so all the
ones that are zoomed in like if you
remember the tow truck versus garbage
truck example
um could just be difficult for somebody
to label
and finally on the rightmost image
cowboy boot or a cowboy hat well in this
case both would apply because the
subject is wearing both of them but in
imagenet
you would be restricted to only choosing
one
so why does class overlap happen
multiple classes can apply to the same
label like we saw with the cowboy boot
cowboy hat example
also the class definitions May overlap
especially when you have many many
classes so for example those dog breeds
so many of them that things can get a
little fuzzy sometimes and yeah on the
boundary groups of samples and this is
basically what we we call groups of
samples that are very difficult for the
model so your class definitions may be
fine maybe the dog breeds you know are
very set in stone there's not really
room for overlap but when you have a
zoomed in photo then things get
confusing and you'll find these like
groups of samples in your data set that
are difficult because of some nature of
the input to the model
so how do you fix Class overlap one way
is to redefine the classes ultimately
it's a problem of class definitions so
you can merge overlapping classes
perhaps they're better off as one class
you can create
um you know or break apart class
hierarchies for example in the laptop or
computer
or in imagenet there's I think like
maybe dog and husky something like that
where one class is essentially a
superset of the other one and you're
always going to get class issues between
those two so it'd be better to break
them apart and recognize that they
belong in separate hierarchies uh and
sometimes it makes sense to create new
classes for example sometimes a lot of
the data sets have just garbage samples
or things that don't relate to the task
and perhaps they would be better suited
for a none category instead of giving
just some like random category to them
and we'll see that later in the demo
also you could migrate to a multi-label
classification task so this is
especially the case when multiple
classes might apply to one image or you
know whatever and in this case you would
allow the model the flexibility to
choose multiple classes or to decide not
to choose a class and besides the
multi-label classification for example
in image classification you could also
move to object detection and that's
perhaps why object detection has been so
popular is that the model can choose to
label you know a number of these objects
or none at all
finally yeah you can provide more
nuanced labeling instructions and this
might just have to happen anyways
because as uh typically folks comb
through their data errors they discover
you know areas that they didn't expect
at first that are giving the labelers
difficulty so perhaps you have to
explain you know what exactly a garbage
truck looks like and what key features
to look out for that would differentiate
it from a tow truck
the third data error cover is data
imbalance and I think this one is
actually perhaps the most interesting
one because of how little attention it
gets in the Academia you know we're all
pretty used to learning about class
imbalance if you've taken machine
learning classes and that's when labels
there can be a large imbalance in your
samples when you break it down by the
ground truth label which can you know
give the model difficulty in learning a
kind of Niche label what doesn't get
talked about and perhaps is just because
we haven't had the frame of mind or the
toolkit to analyze this previously is
data imbalance so this would be
scenarios where you have some data where
there's a lot of duplicates and maybe
other data where there are very few
examples of it and of course the model
is going to overweight essentially to
the data it sees the problem though is
that often the data you have is
um perhaps easier anecdotally versus the
data you actually need so the data you
need the stuff you don't have much of
also tends to be those examples that are
the hardest anyways for somebody to
disambiguate
um yeah
so for example duplicates
um in all of the data sets we've looked
at there have been tons of duplicates
um super classic you know public ones
um imagenet
um I think I don't remember which one
this was but
um you know 0.5 of this data set was
just thank you without any differences
and they don't have to be exact
duplicates either especially in images
uh just small you know rotations or
essentially not even image augmentations
but
um yeah some other kinds of very minor
changes to it will essentially look like
duplicates to the model and and if if
you're unconscious of this it's
essentially like you unconsciously were
re-weighting the loss to focus on
specific scenarios but consciously this
could be a desirable thing to do instead
of Wall Street waiting
outliers for example are also kind of
the opposite of duplicates
um these are you know typically to edge
cases things that
um are indicative of the model's
behavior and production on kind of
undefined regions for example these are
outliers in IMDb Wiki which is a day set
of faces the chair has really nothing to
do with the data set and while the image
on the left is maybe similar it's you
know mostly grayed out
so um you know there's basically some
choice you have to make and really pay
attention to here because this could be
either an example of what where the
model would fail in production or
something that is throwing off its
training because it has nothing to do
with
the rest of the data
and finally kind of in the middle
between duplicates and outliers are
underrepresented samples so on the right
this is a cluster or like clustering of
the similar data in the emotions data
set and so these clusters are
semantically similar groups of samples
where the larger clusters might indicate
that there are more samples of this like
Variety in the data set and yeah so
essentially too much of any one cluster
there would skew the models training and
predictions to focus on that region so
like I mentioned earlier anecdotally the
easiest samples are often also the most
common especially in Industry data sets
income production time fascist and
anecdotal observation but does indicate
that you should consider rebalancing
your data set or downsizing it you know
to avoid the Models Behavior being
biased
so how does one fix data imbalance
really the first step is figuring out a
way to represent the data because once
you have a good representation of it
hopefully that representation helps you
discover these patterns where some
regions are more common than others
traditionally this would look like
perhaps
you know maybe features and statistical
features on the data for example image
histograms or you know word frequency
count vectors you know the engrams
things like that these were kind of more
historical ways to
categorize your data in a way that you
could then look for distributional
differences
um these days what's pretty neat is that
with a large CV LOL models we can get
pretty powerful contextual embeddings
for the data which kind of opens up a
whole new field of ways of organizing
and and showcasing insights in the data
so for example similarity search for
duplicates you can you know take a
sample and look for embeddings that are
similar to it and and those will be
um you know that that's a great way of
finding duplicates the you can perform
the opposite so anomaly detection to
find outliers and general clustering on
the embedding space can help you find
these regions that you can then Rank by
like size and impact on the model's
performance and so that gives you the
regions that are you know
underrepresented or yeah most
contributing to the model's performance
decrease
foreign
and you know an interesting thing
um so you detect these you know an
interesting way to get more data in a
region and there's like several ways but
um using those same embeddings you could
then find similar data from other splits
or other data sets you might have access
to perhaps you know you have a stream of
production data and you're not sure what
to label from it well one way that you
could decide is to use the embeddings to
find similar samples to the most you
know maybe difficult for the model in
training or the most anomalous
examples and
yeah essentially
um collate more examples of this sample
from other data sets
the last data error I'll cover is called
Data drift and essentially you know a
lot of different definitions about data
drift for this case I'll categorize it
as drift is the difference between two
different data distributions so that
could be either two different data sets
or different splits in the same data set
but essentially you're looking for a
scenario where you might want maybe you
don't the the data in two places to look
similar and for some reason it doesn't
and this is an example of like a real
data set where that Island at the top
um didn't exist in the split on the left
so
yeah this can happen over time we saw
this a lot with covid and for example
face recognition where all of a sudden
all of the production data that these
facial recognition models we're seeing
had masks involved and you know it
totally broke them this wasn't this was
you could categorize as like a shift
over time
um yeah and covid in other ways also
affected for example NLP models with
this new term that they had to
um you know account for in coca-19
this can also happen between different
data set splits for example so not
necessarily just over time but in a
given training environment you could
have you know a difference between the
training and validation splits and that
um you could call it generalization so
the generalization data Gap so that
could be an example of a gap between
your understanding of how the model is
going to generalize to actual real world
data data hasn't you know out of
distribution data data hasn't seen
um the difference between validation and
testing that could be called an
evaluation data Gap because that's
essentially the gap between what you
think you know our good metrics maybe on
the validation data but then if testing
is similar to your production
um there could be the Gap could be
indicative of undefined behavior when it
comes to actual production time
and sometimes you know for our customers
they also see these gaps between
different data sets that they use that
they take in from customers and
fine-tune their models on so these are
essentially like the the kind of gaps
they need to address to be able to
generalize their ml models across
multiple scenarios
how does one fix day adrift
um production model monitoring can give
you an estimate of when the model's
performance is degrading so when that
happens you can send some of that
production data to be labeled and then
reevaluate your model's performance on
it see whether those models predictions
lined up with the overall like F1 and
performances you're expecting you can
also monitor changes in the model's
prediction distributions so perhaps it
started to you know it's confidence in
this class has decreased dramatically
from when it was trained on it and that
could be in an early sign that something
is happening in the data
also there's different ways to actually
compare the data itself so one way more
historically would be value-based
distribution differences you know also
this especially like comes up in
structured data if you have columns that
you expect to be within certain
parameters then as they
um you know drift you'd be able to
actually notice it this is harder to do
in unstructured scenarios and that's
where embeddings really can come in and
be helpful because the embeddings give
you a way to to just look for new
clusters that are appearing or ways that
islands are like moving across
um space
and ultimately it boils down to finding
that data difference and adding it to
some corresponding data set if data
drift is a difference between two data
sets then ultimately how we're fixing it
is by you know making them
um bringing them to parity
so to recap we've covered mislabeled
data class overlap data imbalance data
drift there are definitely more data
errors some of these also some of the
data errors also fall Within These but
yeah it's been kind of surprising that I
don't think yet there's been too much
for example like academic classes on the
subject although you know our thesis is
that it's perhaps one of the most
prominent impacts to your model's
performance but hopefully you know that
changes soon there's definitely been a
lot of interest from the research field
in this so yeah if you want to fix these
and more instantly with state-of-the-art
techniques then come try out Galileo
it's available today for free super easy
to sign up and get started with and I'll
just give a quick demo of for example
some of the things you might find in a
data set
so jumping over so this is our website
you can sign up for free and get started
up here we also have links to notebooks
that show how we integrate with the
different model Frameworks that you have
and for now we just support different
NLP task types
okay
going over to what you'll see this is
the newsgroups data set it's one of the
ones we provide as an example when you
sign up and I'm starting to interrupt um
we have five minutes left so just to
make sure we're watching the time thank
you yeah thank you
um yeah so you'll see basically on the
right is an insights chart where they're
the different bar plots that you might
expect to normally see when you're doing
say a text classification problem and
this might indicate to you for example
like hey this particular class has a
much lower F1
correspondingly the number of samples in
this class are lower so you know a quick
fix here would be to add more samples of
this test type
um yeah different like insights that you
might expect to see normally and some of
the data errors we provide out of the
box for example is this likely
mislabeled tab
um you'll see that a lot of these
um are for example this one on the left
talks about baseball and the ground
truth was like medicine but the
prediction and the what the model's
suggesting is that it should be baseball
and similarly down here should be space
um this one talks about guns
um etc etc so yeah then I'll also
showcase so I mentioned a lot in
beddings and how powerful they can be
and so let me go to the embeddings tab
and you'll see this like cartographic
representation of your data and so what
that means is all the data in the data
set is spread out here as your model is
seeing it and so when these classes are
far apart from each other that's because
the model you know has
um defined them very well
um but versus other examples where
things get very confusing like for
example sample down here these are
classes that have to do with religion
and all and often the difference between
like an atheism versus a Christian
versus just the miscategory it can be
pretty confusing
um the last thing I'll showcase is you
know you might have noticed this region
standing out here that has all the
multi-colored points in it and you know
that might be confusing because
um why would the model get confused on a
bunch of data points that have totally
different labels
um well these are all the samples that
are empty and so that for example
immediately jumps out as being confusing
for the model and so if I go ahead and
select this region you'll see the
insights update and that this is a
region where the F1 is super loyal much
lower than our overall F1 if I wanted to
get performance gains I would you know
maybe change the class here essentially
this is an example of class overlap
where these samples are there's not a
clear class definition for examples that
are empty and yeah so maybe I'll change
that label or inform the labelers about
what to do
finally I just want to show how easy it
is to get started with Galileo you can
today install Galileo so install it
through our data quality library and we
have this handy method now called
dq.auto where essentially you provide
your data set and we will run and train
an off-the-shelf hugging face model
behind the scenes for you and you know
essentially give you those outputs of it
automatically in the Galileo console and
why that might be so great is you know
as our thesis is
you can keep the model static
um just change the data and see all the
performance benefits don't worry about
you know the specifics of the
architecture or the hyper parameters
hyper parameters Etc so yeah this is a
very quick way to get started and see
your Data Insights
and that's all I have thank you